[Music]
hi welcome
um
i'm fatini marco pulu i
want to talk about
technology and
what makes us human
and
what would technologies that enhance our
human side may be like in the future
in this environment that is dominated by
technology that we live in so as an
introduction i'm a physicist background
i was in academia for 15 years and in
the last five years
i'm part of a tech company that
we are creating
this emotional second skin if you like
um
that can enhance decision making and
mental health
and just a sense of
balance so
i guess i'll start with why i love
technology
it's actually a very
core thing to
what we are as
an animal we are this special animal
that makes tools
we make technology we always have
that's what technology is these tools
and the thing is that
we make our tools and the tools always
changes
so when we first made tools to kill
animals or make more tools with that's
how we evolved thumbs
so that we could
use our tools better
and it's always been like that we cover
with our tools the technology evolves
we change with it
when we think about technology we tend
to think of our phone or
or the the electronic stuff that we use
or
maybe a power plant but actually there
are
pretty much everything that we make that
we design
is technology
the tools
is what sometimes is called physical
technologies is different ways that we
organize matter into forms that we can
use for a certain purpose
but we also create social technologies
ways to organize ourselves
for a purpose whether that is a tribe
that uh grow stuff or hunt stuff or um a
tribe that creates um new software
um
a supermarket there is a patent for the
first supermarket where you go around
and pick up your own
groceries and then you take them to
check out
these are all technologies ways that we
organize ourselves or we organize the
world around us
and
so
technologies are in layers
um
down to governance and culture these are
all forms of technologies and they all
interact with each other
there all these layers
talk to each other constantly and
through this process
we change
in many levels from actually
physiologically changing
to how we interact with each other and
how we think of ourselves
so in some sense that has always
happened
and
there is a lot of
um a lot to be said about the argument
that you know we always talk about
technology and something special happen
now nothing special happened major
changes have happened before
they can look scary they can look
amazing
uh is there anything special about this
time
and there's an argument that there is
something special about this time
and that is the
between the power of ai and the
data science
we have at least in some areas of our
life we have technologies where the
power of the technology is
similar so the same order of magnitude
as our own so the alphago example is a
case of that
ai has of course its limitations i'm not
going to talk about ai and what it can
do i'm going to focus on
what it might mean when you have
technologies whose if you like cognitive
power is uh
similar
to ours
and
what
what consequence or what choices might
we have in
that landscape
that is the basic question that you
sometimes have to stop a little bit and
think with the stuff that we are making
since we're always co-evolving with this
what is it that we will provoke to with
the technologies that we are creating
and
sometimes especially in the space that i
work in there is
this cyborgy vision of ourselves in the
future where i don't know we plug in
devices or machines uh um i mean i'm
already enhancing my brain with google
it knows so much more than i do i don't
need to remember where anything is
because google maps is going to tell me
so these are all extensions of our
cognitive powers
are we going to be evolving in the
cyborg direction
or what
and in some sense
you know the
when we create technologies we are the
creator and the the question is an old
one um it's are we going to
make
machines
tools in our image
or are we going to worship the machines
and try to make ourselves in the image
of the machines because they seem so
incredibly powerful
so
is this going to be a
future of
human like machines or machine like
humans
now
one of the things that
is i think
psychologically very attractive
to
uh the data science and the idea that
some machines somewhere can crunch
insane amount of data and give us
answers
is the context is the world that we live
in
we are hyper connected we are always on
and
the word seems to just
be more and more messy it's harder to
make sense of it everything is changing
all the time
workplace the future of work is unclear
the there's economic and social
uncertainty a lot does not make sense i
have a complex systems background and i
might just say well it's a complex
system and at this point it's highly
interacting but actually most of the
time it just looks confusing
and so
in this environment is not a huge
surprise that we feel out of balance
unhealthy the mental health problems are
going through the roof
seems like we want to get a grip on
things or
somebody to give us some answers uh a
path
to follow in this
world that is changing so fast all the
time
and it there's a funny way in which
personal tech has inserted itself in
this
but one should look at what has actually
happened
the key driver behind most personal tech
that we interact with
is optimization that means that
the algorithms that go through what are
the new features to add to
attack that a human interacts with um
optimize for
how much time somebody spends using it
because that generally translates into
dollars in fact
the key driver always is optimizing for
dollars
and in this process
uh a strange thing has happened
the science of behavioral psychology
came in
and
gave answers on how to
tweak or
design create technology that attracts
people's attention
the book hooked by niraya was incredibly
um
influential and when it came out it was
like oh my god it's amazing you know
there's all these things that you can
put in your solutions so that people get
hooked
it actually says it on the front page
how to build habit forming products it
seemed like a great idea because you can
build gamification you can build ways to
grab people's attention and then they
keep using your product
and of course the dollar store is coming
now
a little bit
a few years later uh we realized that
actually hooked actually meant hooked
and what these products do is literally
they hijack your reward system your
attention
uh physiologically it's just like
addiction
you get dopamine spikes and you're
addicted to the loops of the dopamine
spikes so these are electronic
addictions at this point we all know
this it's important to remember that
actually it's still the
optimization for attention is still the
main driver behind most of
the personal technologies that you have
now that we know it what do we do
well depends uh what your life is like
so
if
you're lucky enough
to be able to have the time
and mental space to do it you can do
digital detoxes and you can meditate and
you can have your space for yourself and
your children um away
from the technologies that try
to grab you to hijack you
but most people are not in this universe
the my solution
is more tech which
now is
trying to make up for the other tech i'm
not completely sure how it works the way
it works really is that
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you